depuis quelques années on le sait la
population sans cesse croissante à poser
surtout dans les villes des problèmes de
logement alors on a vu se construire un
peu partout grands ensembles des hlm peu
à peu s'est créé là le genre de vie
nouveau et cela n'a pas été sans
difficultés les enfants étaient un peu
laissé à lui même il joué et joue encore
d'ailleurs dans des espaces réduits avec
les mois de juillet et d'août qui
approche désormais à grands pas 50% de
ses enfants ne partiront pas en vacances
ils resteront dans leur vie quoi faire
tuer le temps comme ils le pourront
pendant que leurs parents travaillent
ont pourtant il existe en bretagne à
rennes en particulier des centres aérés
prêt à accueillir tous ces jeunes
ces centres aérés sont ils connus du
public monsieur quinton l'un des
responsables du centre dominique savio
arendt nous répondre
la croissance de la population inquiète
très rapide la même une population qui
ne connaît même pas l'existence des
centrales mais d'autre part les familles
qui envoient régulièrement leurs enfants
bien souvent ignorent ce qui se fait au
centre aéré ses 120 à tous absolument à
tous quelle que soit la situation de
famille de chacun quelle que soit la
situation pécuniaire quelle que soit la
situation hydrologique tous les services
de 100 pays riches pro tellement verra
tous et là je de cjad y viennent dans
les centres et bien nous avons plusieurs
couples d'âge différent nous commencions
les prendre l'a4 en groupe de 4 à 6 ans
nous appelons les doubles et prirent
nous avons des groupes de quartiers
répartis sur le terrain de 7 à 14 ans et
nous avons des groupes adolescents et
adolescentes de 14 et 17 ans oui c'est à
dire de 4 à 17 ans vous avez tous les
jeunes j s'ils le désirent ici nous
sommes au centre dominique savio tous
les jours donc pendant les vacances les
enfants pourront venir s'amuser leurs
parents eux seront tranquilles garçons
et filles étant surveillé par des
moniteurs spécialisés
mais l'an dernier combien d'enfants sont
venus au centre
l'an dernier il est passé près de 3000
enfants dans les deux sens et si vous
êtes accro medic savions nous avons
supprimé bernadette soubirous et il
viendra davantage de garçons que les
filles
oui et autres
2 5 millions les vacances ont été prises
dans ces centres aériens situés à la
porte de rennes
quelles sont les activités sont
proposées aux jeunes sont mises à
disposition des jeunes
mais ces activités sont extrêmement
variées en fonction de la qualification
ont reçu par les militaires au cours du
centre et au cours des stages de
perfectionnement une formation en fait
en cours d'année j'ai connu asséné lui
et ses activités vend depuis les
enjeu d'à travers les bois qui sont
entraînements restent ici puisque vous
avez un ensemble de 18 hectares sur le
terrain elle quoi s'amuser
il ya de la place où se battre on fait
donc des grands jeux qui permettent de
se dépenser beaucoup dans les bois on
joue évidemment wallon en compte partout
mais à côté de ça on a aussi pas mal
d'ateliers qui vont du plâtre de la
pyrogravure que le très apprécié au
retail corps d'armée comme bricolage
points en poissons et ses 4 de bricolage
et enfin bien sûr la piscine et bien sûr
la piscine de cette piscine qui fait
tant le plaisir aux jeunes et qui nous
auraient permis depuis deux ans chaque
année de distribuer de permettre la
jeunesse et sports de distribuer de 300
brevets de natation alors qu'ils vont
tout simplement 25 mètres jusqu'à 3000 m
oui enfin pour les plus jeunes pour la
section de 4 à 6 ans est-ce que vous
avez ici des projets d'avenir
oui nous avons des projets en cours de
réalisation immédiate
il s'agit d'un bâtiment que nous
construisons car depuis quatre ans nous
avons ces petits et nous n'avons pas de
locaux pratiquement les habite et gilles
ça nous a posé d'énormes problèmes au
cours des dernières heures ce dernier
centre aéré et ses locaux actuels de
l'iss à dakar et vont nous permettre de
se gardant bien meilleures conditions
tous ces petits de plus en plus de tels
centres secrets en bretagne et c'est
tant mieux ils sont utiles indispensable
même pour les enfants qui ne sont plus
désormais livrés à eux mêmes